lo que haremos en este vídeo será ver un
ejemplo específico para calcular la
velocidad angular y relacionar esto con
el concepto de rapidez comencemos con
este ejemplo de nuevo tenemos una pelota
atada con una cuerda a un centro de
rotación por lo que si queremos mover
esta pelota ésta se moverá en círculos
en cualquiera de estas direcciones la
cuerda tiene una longitud de 7 metros y
sabemos que cuando el tiempo es igual a
tres segundos el ángulo theta es igual a
pi entre dos radiales en vídeos
anteriores vimos que el ángulo se mide a
partir de la parte positiva del eje x y
digamos que cuando el tiempo es igual a
6 segundos theta es igual a pi radiales
así que después de tres segundos la
pelota se encontrará aquí si queremos
visualizar como ocurre esto vamos a
rotar esta pelota en tres segundos en un
segundo dos segundos tres segundos vamos
a hacerlo de nuevo en un segundo dos
segundos tres segundos
ahora que visualizamos lo que ocurre
pausa en el vídeo y calculen dos cosas
primero calculan la velocidad angular de
la pelota y de todos los puntos que
conforman esta cuerda la velocidad
angular la denotamos con la letra omega
y después calculen la rapidez de la
pelota traten de encontrar estos dos
valores y para ganar puntos extra traten
de encontrar la relación entre estos dos
conceptos supongo que ustedes ya
hicieron los cálculos así que ahora
comencemos calculando la velocidad
angular recuerden que la velocidad
angular es igual al desplazamiento
angular delta teta que es una cantidad
vectorial que vamos a dividir entre el
cambio en el tiempo del tate el
desplazamiento angular es igual al
ángulo final que es pi radian es menos
el ángulo inicial que spears entre dos
radiales
todo esto lo vamos a dividir entre el
cambio en el tiempo que es el tiempo
final seis segundos menos el tiempo
inicial tres segundos en el numerador
queda pi entre dos radiales positivo y
como es positivo sabemos que la rotación
fue en sentido antihorario esto ocurrió
en tres segundos podemos reescribir esto
como
entre 6 y no olvidemos las unidades el
cambio en el ángulo está en radiales y
esto es por segundo así que tenemos pi
entre 6 radiales por segundo si esto
ocurre durante tres segundos tendremos
pie entre dos radiales ya que tenemos
esto vamos a calcular la rapidez si no
lo han hecho aún pausa en el vídeo y
traten de calcularlo por su cuenta la
rapidez es igual a la distancia
recorrida por la pelota como hemos visto
en otros vídeos y si aún no los han
visto los invito a que lo hagan la
distancia recorrida la denotamos con la
letra s mayúscula no se confundan con la
letra s minúscula que usamos para
representar la unidad de medida de los
segundos la s mayúscula significa la
longitud de arco o la distancia
recorrida así que la rapidez va a ser
igual a la longitud de arco dividida
entre el cambio en el tiempo pero a que
es igual la longitud de arco vimos en un
vídeo anterior la relación entre la
longitud de arco y la distancia la
longitud de arco es la magnitud del
cambio en el desplazamiento angular
multiplicado por el radio
en este caso nuestro radio es de 7
metros sustituimos todo esto aquí y que
vamos a tener tenemos que la rapidez es
igual a la distancia recorrida que es la
magnitud del desplazamiento angular
multiplicada por el radio de la
circunferencia sobre la que ocurre el
movimiento todo esto entre el cambio en
el tiempo si sustituimos los valores
tenemos que la magnitud del
desplazamiento angular es pi entre 2 el
radio que es la longitud de la cuerda es
siete metros y el cambio en el tiempo es
tres segundos así que podemos calcular
todo esto pero lo interesante aquí es
darnos cuenta de qué significa esta
parte de la fórmula que es la magnitud
del desplazamiento angular entre el
cambio en el tiempo es el valor absoluto
de la velocidad angular así que podemos
decir que la rapidez es igual al valor
absoluto de la velocidad angular
multiplicado por el radio en este caso
la rapidez va a ser igual a pi entre 6
radiales por segundo lo escribimos
multiplicado por el radio que es igual a
7 metros y nos queda 7 pi entre 6 metros
por segundo que son las unidades de
rapidez
la razón por la que usamos el valor
absoluto de la velocidad angular es
porque la rapidez es una cantidad
escalar no vamos a especificar la
dirección de hecho cada instante que se
mueve la pelota está cambia de dirección
constantemente hemos logrado lo que
queríamos de hecho hay varias maneras de
resolver este tipo de preguntas pero lo
importante aquí es que primero
calculemos la velocidad angular y
después veamos cómo relacionar la
velocidad angular con la rapidez lo
bueno es que tenemos una bonita y
sencilla fórmula para hacerlo todo esto
viene de cosas que aprendimos en la
secundaria sobre la circunferencia del
círculo y que vimos en el vídeo que
relaciona el desplazamiento angular con
la longitud de arco o distancia
recorrida
nos vemos en otro vídeo